[Music]
well after that busy summer that
included the summer olympic games and a
handful of aces coming home with gold
they polished that off a memory now and
they're focused on the wnba title and
the first postseason performance was
tonight in game one of their best of
five series with the phoenix mercury
it's a two versus a five seed las vegas
favor and they've been resting now for
what nine days while phoenix is coming
off a winner of the defending champion
seattle in a one-and-done game now early
on it took a while for the
vegas team to find its legs but they did
they fell behind by nine but they
climbed them out make a run
raquana williams with 17 first half
points chelsea gray pitching in with 11
after trending by nine aces lead 52-49
at the break now second half it was
kelsey plum who comes to life she was
scoring outside and in the paint she
scored 25 points in 15 minutes of play
four aces in double figures plum and
williams combined for 51 of the aces 96
points and vegas wins it 96-90 and
credit the aces hustle and those second
chance points
i mean i think kia stokes was a huge
part of that she is just up there
touching every ball i think jackie gets
in there and did some like logo rebounds
asia has just been a monster awards uh
lately um
and i just think you know for us and we
have dear that comes in and does that as
well um so yeah i mean it's great second
chest points anything we'll take
anything right now